-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
Mark Wahlberg right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, one of our favorites.
And we always like
to do something fun
when you're on the show.
You're a good sport.
Thank you for doing that.
Since we're both competitive,
I thought we could compete
in a series of challenges --
challenges we can get done
in just 30 seconds.
It's time for "30 Seconds To..."
Here we go.
♪ 30 Seconds To... ♪
-so we have 30 seconds to...
blank.
That's the way the game works.
For this first challenge,
we'll have 30 seconds
to fill our cups with as many
green Skittles as we can.
Thank you.
Whoever gets the most, wins.
So just only green Skittles.
I feel like you have more green
in your bowl.
Already this feels rigged to me.
-It's just
a Boston Celtic thing.
It looks that way,
but it's not, really.
-Yeah. It's a Boston thing.
Alright.
We have 30 seconds on the clock.
Ready, set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God. This is not good.
-Oh, no.
I put an orange one in there.
-It's going like a -- Yeah,
now you got to clean it out.
-I messed up. I messed up.
-That's --
-Yeah, that's -- That's where --
Quest, you're making me nervous!
-Oh, no.
-How many seconds?
Oh. I got a red one there.
Eight.
Audience: 8, 7, 6...
-Ah. God.
-...5, 4, 3...
2, 1!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I got a couple of others
in there.
-What do we -- How do we know?
We have to count them out?
-I just figured if I went back
and just started
taking them out,
you lost so much time, man.
-Oh, wait. So you already have
other colors.
So I totally win.
I win that one, right?
-You got that one.
-Alright. I got that one.
Cool. Cheers. Right?
-It looks like edamame.
-Right? Yeah, hang on.
[ Applause ]
Alright, who went -- Wait.
You're getting them out
as you're pulling them out
and counting them?
Alright. I have this many.
One, two...
I got, like, 15 or something.
What do you got?
-I got more than 15.
-You do? Oh, yeah.
You crushed me.
Mark Wahlberg wins that one.
-I -- I didn't have
the right amount.
[ Bell dinging ]
-You win round one.
-You like to win
and then say you lost.
-No -- Yeah, exactly.
-I see the game.
[ Cup bounces ]
-Alright, here we go.
For this next challenge --
For this next challenge,
we'll have 30 seconds
to see who can get the most
ping-pong balls
into a red Solo cup.
-Oh, gosh.
-I think --
I don't even know if I --
-Beer pong.
-I don't even know
if I can get one in.
-I think you play this game
for a living.
Professional beer ponger.
-Actually, I am.
Yeah, I get paid on the show
to play beer pong.
It's a great gig, man.
It's a great gig.
Alright. Let's get 30 seconds
on the clock.
-For real, I don't think
I'm going to make one.
-Alright, good luck.
Here we go.
Go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, [bleep].
I'm not even in the area.
I don't even have the right --
No, I'm not even close.
-I -- I -- Now I'm drifting.
-Oh, my gosh.
I haven't hit the cup yet.
-I'm throwing two at a time now.
♪♪
I got one. I got one!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I got one in.
-Yeah, I got one, too.
Oh, I got two!
-I got it.
-Ooh.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is amaz--
-I got a lot of rim.
-Amazing skill. Yeah.
I got --
-Oh, no, I got --
-How many did you get?
-I got two.
-That's interesting,
because I got three!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
We had a good strategy
right there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Alright, we're tied up.
We're tied up and we're down
to the final challenge, okay?
-He's gonna have to pick up
all the balls.
-And this is the --
-Sorry about that. I apologize.
-No, this is -- this is fun.
This is "The Tonight Show."
It's what it should be.
Ping-pong balls everywhere.
This final challenge,
we have 30 seconds to stick
as many Post-it notes
to our bodies as we can.
-Oh, boy.
-Whoever sticks the most Post-it
notes on their body wins.
You ready for this?
-They took your --
half your stack.
-Yeah. Yeah, I do -- I feel
like my stack is little, yeah.
Thanks. Appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
Okay, now I have more.
Now this feels weird.
Oh, you have some there.
Alright.
Alright, ready for this?
Can we do that? Is that okay?
Alright. Let's get 30 seconds
on the clock.
On your mark. Get set. Go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I went too thick.
It's harder than you think!
Your -- It sticks to your face
pretty well.
-You got to do multiple.
♪♪
-There you go.
-Oh, I'm losing them.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's not even a comparison.
-I got --
-I think we all know who
the winner is right there,
the one and only.
[ Bell dinging ]
Mark Wahlberg! The champ!
Guys, his movie "Me Time"
is available on Netflix
August 26th with Kevin Hart.
Billy Porter joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.